L'informatique quantique est entrée dans l'ère de l'utilité,
ce qui signifie qu'on peut commencer à utiliser les ordinateurs quantiques pour résoudre
des problèmes du monde réel, y compris certains qui sont très difficiles
pour les ordinateurs classiques.
Un thème récurrent à l'ère actuelle,
c'est qu'un problème est résolu
pour la première fois sur un ordinateur quantique,
puis des gens trouvent ensuite un moyen de le faire sur un ordinateur classique.
Ce cycle entre l'informatique classique
et l'informatique quantique qui se poussent mutuellement à leurs
limites va probablement se poursuivre
encore quelques années. Il existe des classes de problèmes pour lesquelles l'informatique
quantique peut offrir un avantage démontrable
sur l'informatique classique,
compte tenu des progrès dans des domaines tels
que la réduction des erreurs et le nombre de qubits disponibles.
Il existe aussi des domaines d'application entiers
où l'informatique quantique
pourrait être utile dans un avenir relativement proche.
L'un de ces domaines est l'apprentissage automatique quantique, ou QML.
L'apprentissage automatique quantique désigne
l'application de l'informatique quantique à tout type de processus
d'apprentissage automatique. Il existe bien sûr
de nombreux types d'apprentissage automatique.
Deux types présentent un intérêt particulier :
l'apprentissage supervisé, dans lequel tu
entraînes un algorithme à l'aide d'un jeu de données étiqueté,
et l'apprentissage non supervisé, dans lequel
l'algorithme travaille à partir d'échantillons non étiquetés
et tente d'apprendre la distribution
ou la fonction qui la génère.
Un algorithme non supervisé peut
par exemple apprendre à générer de nouveaux échantillons
issus de la même distribution, ou encore
regrouper les échantillons en groupes aux caractéristiques similaires.
L'apprentissage supervisé et non supervisé impliquent souvent
l'intégration de données dans des espaces de dimension supérieure,
et la manipulation de données dans des espaces de dimension supérieure
devrait nous faire penser à l'informatique quantique.
Laisse-moi t'expliquer. Imagine que tu essaies de résoudre le problème de savoir si
tu dois classer un point de données du plan
comme un cercle ou une croix, d'après les données d'entraînement étiquetées ici.
Parfois, les données peuvent être clairement séparées par une ligne
ou un plan en basse dimension,
comme illustré ici, et classifier ces points de données selon
ceux qui sont au-dessus de la ligne
et ceux qui sont en dessous ne pose
aucun problème. Mais regarde cette distribution :
il n'existe manifestement aucune ligne visible qui sépare les points de données.
Cependant, pour ces données, on pourrait imaginer une certaine
correspondance des deux dimensions vers trois dimensions,
de sorte qu'après avoir appliqué cette correspondance, nos données ressemblent
à ceci, et il y a clairement un plan qui sépare les deux
classes, que l'on peut utiliser
pour la classification. Si ce traitement te semble un peu simpliste,
tu as raison : on ne peut pas simplement placer les points de données qu'on veut
plus haut sans justification.
Il doit y avoir une correspondance
à partir de la distribution 2D qui sépare efficacement
nos points de données, afin qu'on puisse
utiliser cette correspondance pour classifier de nouveaux points de données.
Cela sera abordé plus en détail dans la leçon offrant un récapitulatif
sur l'apprentissage automatique, mais il suffit de dire
que le problème peut être vu
comme le test de nombreuses correspondances différentes dans cet espace de dimension supérieure
pour voir lesquelles donnent la meilleure
séparation des points de données de différentes classes.
Cette manipulation de données en haute dimension
est un domaine où l'informatique quantique
peut avoir un impact majeur. Pour comprendre pourquoi,
revenons aux différences entre l'informatique classique
et l'informatique quantique. Tout comme
les ordinateurs classiques utilisent des bits d'information,
les ordinateurs quantiques utilisent des qubits.
Mais pour un nombre donné de bits, disons quatre,
un ordinateur classique peut prendre l'une des
deux à la puissance quatre, soit seize valeurs d'état possibles.
Un ordinateur quantique peut lui aussi accéder à seize états possibles,
mais il peut exister en superposition de tous
les seize états simultanément,
et des opérations peuvent être effectuées sur toute cette superposition.
Pour quatre qubits, ça ne semble peut-être pas
si impressionnant, mais imagine ce qu'on pourrait faire avec
un ordinateur quantique à deux à la puissance vingt ou
deux à la puissance cent vingt-sept
états simultanément. Il existe de nombreuses autres différences
entre l'informatique classique et l'informatique quantique qui vont
toutes jouer un rôle dans ce domaine.
Les états quantiques ont des amplitudes de probabilité complexes.
Les manipulations des systèmes quantiques sont effectuées avec
des opérateurs unitaires, et les ordinateurs quantiques sont soumis à des
types de bruit différents de ceux des ordinateurs classiques.
Ces différences vont surgir
tout au long de ton travail en apprentissage automatique quantique, dans des domaines
comme l'encodage des données, le feature mapping et la mitigation des erreurs.
Dans certains cas, ces différences entre l'informatique classique
et l'informatique quantique nous permettent de concevoir des algorithmes
entièrement nouveaux. Voilà qui était un aperçu très bref
de l'union de deux domaines immensément complexes,
mais j'espère que deux choses sont claires :
l'apprentissage automatique résout souvent des problèmes
en manipulant des données dans des dimensions très élevées,
et deuxièmement, les ordinateurs quantiques sont bien adaptés
à la manipulation de données en haute dimension,
et le font différemment des systèmes classiques.
Cela devrait te donner une idée
des raisons pour lesquelles l'apprentissage automatique est un domaine prometteur
pour l'application de l'informatique quantique utile.